[Music]
all right it's time to get cooking with
nanny bubbe
and today she's making mascarpone and
lemon thyme gnocchi
with thyme terrigan butter sauce in
other words it's something very yummy
how are you nanny bobby it's great to
see you i
am great jc so nice to see you as well
so i have to tell you that we're
starting with the back side of this
showing you the completed gnocchi over
here and we're going to be putting it
into the dish just a note to
the control room we cannot see anything
on our camera so we don't know what
we're shooting
if you can correct that on your end but
i'll continue plowing through
this is the gnocchi that we're making
this is brown butter sauce this is going
to be sitting over here
and what i'm going to do now is show you
exactly how to make it and just a word
to the wise
as you take gnocchi and you put it onto
the sheet pan
you can take this and just freeze your
sheet pan overnight
for three to four hours at the at the
least amount of time and overnight and
then you can just take your gnocchi
throw it in a ziploc bag and then pull
it out anytime you want
so the thing about nokia is it sounds so
daunting to make gnocchi but it's
actually so simple so
let's get cooking and i'll show you how
to do it okay so we're going to
start with easy by the way thank you so
much
thank you thank you so much i appreciate
it eight ounces a cup
of mascarpone cheese which is italian
cream cheese
over here with that we're going to put
in a cup of parmesan cheese
there we go freshly grated and then
we're going to put in
two lemons that have been zested there
we go
less zested one quarter of a teaspoon of
nutmeg
can you see that in the bowl are you
able to get in the bowl
and we're going to take it back on the
screen about a tablesp about a
tablespoon at a time and then leave the
rest for
sprinkling as we get to the end and then
we're going to take two eggs so this is
the tip of the day
never put an egg just in whatever you're
mixing whether it's gnocchi or
cake or whatever it is first crack it
into a bowl because you can get a bad
egg
and if you cracked it into this bowl
well you would have to actually
throw out the whole batter and you don't
want to do this so that's
one egg and one egg yolk there we go
let's just let the egg whoa let me just
pull that egg yolk out
right into here there we go and we're
done with that
okay so we're just going to mix it
really lightly with a fork
mix it all in and then we're going to
add the flour
so just in the interest of time let me
just show you how easy this
is especially once the mascarpone is
room temperature here we go and you're
just going to mix this all
up with a fork till it becomes a really
really sticky sticky sticky dough so i'm
going to hand this off to intern megan
and this dough was made just a little
bit earlier today and what you do is you
take two spoons like this
and just make a really cool little oval
and then
drop it into a pie plate just with
all-purpose flour
that you use to make your gnocchi
right into there let me turn this off
we'll do just one more
don't you love my sound effects i work
very hard on this every week
that's the key when you're making this
this weekend for your family you've got
to do this
yeah there you go so we're sprinkling
this with flour
and then we're i'm just going to roll
them into like little ovals
shuffle all the dough off ready thumb in
and then you roll it with your three
fingers this is a gnocchi roller you can
get it on amazon and there you go just
like that
one more there we go if you make a
mistake
just start again so there you go here we
have
taken this gnocchi we are just putting
the brown butter sauce over the top like
this
we're going to put pecorino romano
cheese over the top of the gnocchi
just like that some time and a little
sprinkle of time
and now do i have time no pun intended
to taste it oh let us know how good it
is
it looks delicious oh my god looks
delicious i wish you were here or i were
there
so good the lemon
that's it well you know natty bubby the
show ends at 3 30. rocky and i can be
there by four o'clock if you want to
save something for us
okay come along i've got a platter full
and more dough that i'm going to mix
over there and get it done but at the
end of the day what are we going to do
we're going to go out and spread love
like
butter like butter of course i know that
that's what i'm doing this weekend
yeah there you go have a great great
weekend and enjoy your gnocchi
same to you nanny bubby check out nanny
bubby's kitchen and garden on social
media and online at nannybubby.com
and thank you to chapman automotive for
sponsoring this segment